I'm particularly honored to be
interviewing you today because as many
of the students know I actually worked
at Blackstone before coming to the GSB
and let's just say we were a few
paygrades apart back then so I'm
thrilled to be sitting here with you and
having a conversation for the next 40
minutes good so I want to take this
opportunity and along with all of my
classmates here to really get to know
you more as a person as a leader and as
someone who has great insights about the
industry and I want to walk away from it
getting a few advice from you and that
we can apply to our professional and
personal lives to get started I want to
say that people here all know you as CEO
of Blackstone one of the largest asset
management companies here but most
people might not know is you're actually
an entrepreneur I want to take us back
to 1985 when you were a head of merger
and acquisition group at Lehman Brothers
but you decided to leave and start your
own company with your co-founder Pete
Peterson that was during the time when
private equity was very new and
considered a very risky asset and you
and Pete neither neither of you had a
track record and investing so can you
talk about how did you overcome these
early challenges well I that was some
time ago but immense pain keeps you in
touch with that time and it being an
entrepreneur is much better after you're
successful then when you're thinking
about it and let alone thinking about it
doing it because the beginning of most
things is very very difficult more
difficult than you imagined or because
otherwise more people would do it and
the failure rate is quite high as you
know it used to be like nine
ten new enterprises fail I'm not sure
because I'm not in the academic world
exactly what the number is but it's hi
what we did is you have to effort I sold
Lehman to American Express company in
1984 I stayed for a year and then Pete
and I left to start our new business but
what is interesting is I found that that
the most important thing about a new
business is is figuring out what you're
doing before you're doing it in other
words why does anybody need you there
were plenty of people in finance when I
was in it of 1985 but you have to offer
something that's that's distinctive and
to do that you have to think through
what what your strategy is and so so
Pinay used to meet every morning for
like three hours at Hotel because we
didn't even have an office it's like
your garage concept I guess and and and
you know we think about what do we want
to be what do we want to do why should
anybody like want to do anything with us
other than the fact that we were
friendly and lovable which apparently
isn't enough to to basically prove
victorious
except in your own conference from
meeting only with yourself and where you
always win by the way that's still we're
very successful in our own conference
room that that what we did is we tried
to say okay here's I call this a great
fantasy right you have to have great
fantasies in life and then realize them
so our fantasy was what did we want to
be when we grew up
um first we wanted to be in the MMA
business because they didn't want to
raise capital we wanted to keep owning
the whole firm that was a cash flow
business why not just do that it's easy
we knew the people we found out it
wasn't easy we didn't know the people
but
second part was the at that point the
private equity business was pretty much
of a low no-brainer prices were low
capital was available weren't many
people in it that was a way of also
raising management fees at that time
because you wanted predictable income
don't I'm always in the risk
minimization business and the third
thing because the industry was
restructuring was to basically take
advantage of the fact that there were
like a host of little firms to
consolidate into only a few big ones and
and when I joined Lehman we had 550
people when it died it had around 30,000
the difference between working in a
place with five hundred some-odd people
is you know everyone by sight you may
not know their names you know them by
sight it's possible to have a cohesive
environment when you have 30,000 people
it doesn't feel the same and I always
like the small feeling and so I figured
if I like the small feeling a bunch of
other people would too and so as the
firms were consolidating you'd have
great people you never could normally
attract but they'd be there so the the
challenge was to figure out what these
kinds of new areas is and we called them
and I'm not trying to make this about
Blackstone particularly I'm just giving
you a sense of how to approach an
entrepreneurial situation we called them
affiliates and we set them up as 50/50
deals and and we didn't know what they'd
be but we knew they needed three
criteria the first was an amazing
investment opportunity so good even a
non manager like myself could not screw
it up secondly we wanted to attract
somebody to run it who was at end on a
scale of 10 because you'll find in your
careers if you're a 10 god bless you
you'll be wildly successful if you
attract tens they always make it rain if
you need rain and they
just have an ability to sense problems
design solutions do new things and
that's what @n does a nine is graded
executing can come up with good
strategies but not great strategies a
firm full of nines that's a winning firm
eight they just sort of do stuff that
you tell them and sevens and below I
don't know what they are so so so so
because this we don't tolerate them so
so it doesn't work in our industry may
work in other industries doesn't work in
our industry so so the third part of
these affiliates of which are now folded
into Blackstone was was to make sure
they're manufacturing intellectual
capital that enhances the business we
already air in so because you're in the
constant intellectual capital building
business forget that we're called money
managers or wherever else we want to
call us that's really our business right
and so it's just a question of waiting
for one of those opportunities and then
acting on and and that's was our plan
and at the time we did it
there was no independent investment
banking boutique didn't exist but we
figured with only you know the arrogance
that you could have when you're young
that if they were doing this huge amount
of merger and acquisition business with
us when we were called Lehman Brothers
why wouldn't the same two people do it
when it was just some made-up name like
Blackstone and we just assumed we'd be
successful by the way that was not
universally helped as a belief because
we'd go to the same people and they
wouldn't hire us and we said well why
would you hire us we like the same
people and we have the same knowledge
base and they said well we don't even
know what you are some little thing why
how can we hire you so you had to
convince them that you could do the same
thing you did the day before you started
sort of odd isn't it I mean can you
imagine if you were like a football
player and you were Heisman Trophy
winner and you just changed teams and
nobody would let you play because you
only could play with the other uniform
just doesn't make sense but that was the
world so so that worked and we finally
managed to convince the people and we
started all these businesses and now
we're the biggest in the world at what
we do because and we're still five
following the same basic plan but one
thing just as a entrepreneurial you must
be crazy thing when we did our first
private equity fund we sent out 488
offering circulars to people we knew I
ended up with 32 investors and they all
didn't come at the beginning so I don't
know how often you like to be rejected
but try it that many times my math
skills aren't that good but it's got to
be somewhere around 350 something 450
something rejections people who look at
you and you have a meeting where they
consider you and I don't know if any of
you remember the movie Gladiator
but the Emperor sits there and he goes
and it's about you it's it's not a
product it's you you're a loser and how
many times can you be told you're a
loser the answer apparently is almost
infinite and and and and so anybody
who's been through a process like that
ends up is a much nicer more humble
person no matter where you started
because the world is telling you you are
a loser and we ended up raising the
biggest first time fund in history with
two people who had never made an
investment just by force of will so it
does show you that force of will counts
it counts and and you'd be amazed at the
number of people who reject you who are
completely dishonest one of my favorite
ones and my friend I had many favorite
ones but one of my favorite ones was the
head of one of the biggest banks in the
world who we'd saved on some disaster by
restructuring it and and it was a very
difficult situation for them anyhow we
thought they'd be nice and throw us ten
million dollars which is the time was a
lot of money and you know we had a
meeting with him he's a famous guy you
know you'd invite him out here maybe he
was here uh and he said to us you know
you're you're really good people we give
you money but we just don't do this type
of investing we're a bank we don't we
don't do this so you know sometimes
you're defeated by structure and we sort
of slumped out of his office and and
some reason this man for God that my
partner's wife was on his board of
directors I I don't know exactly how he
forgot that and she told us that in fact
they were regularly approving these
types of investments you save the person
you save their job the guy just lies to
you
it's stunning is it really stunning so
for all of you people out there who want
to be entrepreneurs you got to have a
thick skin you you almost need some
friendly psychologist training you're
traipsing around with you to buck you up
from all the setbacks that you have it's
always great after your Jack Ma but it's
not so great you know if you file a
chapter and and the difference in that
you know Jack's at 10 he almost did go
down several times
it's that scrambling ability the ability
to take that kind of abuse and rejection
and believe in your basic plan but be
adaptable and just keep going it's it's
really difficult as you can see it's you
know that was quite some time ago it's
29 years ago it's still a searing
experience and now you know we have this
wonderful business with people like this
and I couldn't even get hired at our
firm now I'm not smart enough but and
it's it's fantastic we turn out these
great results year after year after year
and it's easy now but these early years
where you'll find that your own
capabilities which you think are
remarkable are perhaps not exactly
suited for purpose and you have to hire
someone else you have to do something
else you never sleep because of the fear
of failure and if you don't have that
fear you'll stay asleep you will fail
you know because it takes these kind of
remarkable human effort to overcome a
world that isn't as anxious for you as
you are for it and if you know it's good
that you have to be fundamentally
delusional to get out there on the field
of battle and make it happen
and we invent new things all the time I
love it that's what I spend I spend a
lot of time doing
a lot of things but in terms of stuff
that I really enjoy it's starting new
things and bringing them into reality
and you know the idea I'm running a
really consequential big company of some
type is a bit of a mystery because I
think it's all just to start up and and
one of the other things is if you lose
that sense that that things have to be
done right that other organizations
people and so forth are trying to you
know sort of succeed at your expense
then your organization becomes
vulnerable you become sloppy you become
self-confident
and you can never ever let that happen
and there are examples that you study
all the time I mean that's why I think
business schools exist is to look at
these sort of train wrecks of companies
that used to be great that stopped being
great lost their their vision wandered
around became self-confident and people
came to work believing that things would
be fine the next day because they always
happen it's not necessarily like that
you know somebody's always innovating
somebody's always trying to do better
and if it's your expense then you're
just as you're just a victim and your
jobs are not to be victims it's to have
someone else be a victim that was very
inspiring Steve
thank you at least I might take away
from that was if I walk out and face
rejections I'll know Steve has faced
more all all jokes aside we actually
want to now move forward and as you
mentioned the 29 years you've built
Blackstone and you've really built it
into a diversified platform with many
distinct business lines an alternative
investment so a lot of people think it's
actually very difficult to be a founder
and a CEO and Mike because it actually
takes different traits to do both but
you've clearly succeeded in doing both
so my question to you is do you agree
with that statement and if so how did
you make that transition
I agree completely it's these are
different kinds of skills somebody once
said to me that no one was born as a CEO
there's not a CEO gene it's a trained
behavior not a necessarily an intuitive
one and you know being an entrepreneur
is a different set of skills I've
learned a lot and I've done this now for
29 years so there's a lot of evolution I
made a whole bunch of mistakes earlier
you know our business is history because
I actually didn't really know what to do
it and I got a little coaching from my
partner who had been a CEO twice before
but there's a whole skill set of
learning to be s CEO first of all I mean
I'm sure you have classes that teach
this but when it's done live it's it's
it's different one of the things that
that is that you have to recognize when
your CEO is people listen to you way
more and then you'd think and and they
amplify everything that you say and and
so you have to be exceptionally careful
about what you say even just sort of a
joke can get misinterpreted people look
for you know your approbation your
praise you you can't give it unless it's
deserved but but if it's deserved you
have to be really generous doing that
because because people respond to it and
it's important you have to realize that
human beings are not like parts of a
deal you know and a deal it's a pretty
much of a closed system what one person
gets the other one loses and that's the
way it is with an ongoing team of really
terrific people you can't manage that
way you sometimes you see a problem and
you have to game it out if if people
were just like like chess pieces you
know you just sort of move them and it's
over but they're not and you know
sometimes you can see a problem and and
you have to strategize it out so so if
you're moving people around you don't
want anybody particularly to lose
confidence in themselves you want to be
nice to everybody but you want to
accomplish the objective so sometimes it
could take two years to do something
that you know should happen in ten
minutes
but if you did it then you break so much
glass through the organization that
you'd threaten the institution or you'd
threaten core people and there's a way
to work that out so so time actually you
know as opposed to some some cartoon
like squash buckling CEO it doesn't work
that way you you have to be careful with
every move you have to give people
dignity but you have to accomplish your
objectives so time is something that you
give up some
times to do that and you also have to
articulate the core values of your
business and you can never stop doing
that and you can never stop doing that
enough everybody has to know what you
stand for and they have to see you a lot
as a CEO because that way organizations
don't lose their soul on the other hand
you have to surround yourself with
phenomenal people who share that value
system and there's a very interesting
almost internal debate you have to go
through between control and seating
control because nobody wants to work at
a place if they're brilliant terrific
people like we have if they're so
tightly controlled they don't they don't
feel they have any autonomy or dignity
and it may be an issue in finance not
some other industries so you have to
develop controls and the nobody can blow
up the the firm but autonomy enough so
that everybody thinks that that they
have self-worth and importance and can
utilize their their gifts it is very
useful as a CEO to have plans to expand
your business not for earnings per share
reasons interestingly it's so everybody
in the organization can grow up and not
be forced out so you start new
businesses because most people in an
audience of the type that I'm speaking
to don't want to be subordinated work
units that's what they called them in
the 1980s you all want to be at least
brigadier General's if not more you
don't want to be like a private or
corporal you want to be in charge of
your destiny you're not so unusual most
people would like to have ownership
of their own growth so so part of being
a CEO is figuring out how can you
provide that for everybody and one way
to do that is to start new businesses
where people can move up and and
exercise you know their creative
abilities you know so that you know a
firm is continually entrepreneurial so
so it was a big step for me to slow down
because I was like a deal person and
that's a different world and and and
just learned how to do that and it's
it's a transition and you make mistakes
while you're doing that but after you've
done it for a long time I I actually
have fun with like people who are newly
appointed CEOs though they'll call me up
and say can I have lunch with you can
you tell me how to do this job and
because they don't know and the smart
ones know they don't know and and you
know none of us know everything but
they're they're like helpful hints as to
how to do that
thank you Steve I want to switch gears a
little bit and talk about your
leadership because view from the top as
you know is a series of leadership we
want to know what was your personal
leadership philosophy that led you to
lead Blackstone over the past 29 years
no what I've always been a leader you
know I was like one of those Student
Council choose your high school people
and you know you know president your
high school people and did stuff in
college like that did stuff in business
school like that so I don't I don't know
how I got that way I've always been like
that
I've always enjoyed being in charge of
things and doing new things and and I
remember I brought a rock group that was
that was famous at the time to my high
school and everybody said it couldn't be
done I thought it would be fun and you
know sort of interesting so I liked
new things and I like being a leader and
I like dealing with complexity and I
like dealing with problems I like
creating and usually that's the best
spot to be in so here we have a course
at the GSB
it's called touchy feely it was many of
you might have taken it here basically
it's about how to be a leader by being
more aware of your emotional reactions
and building deeper connections with
people through self disclosure
vulnerability and really showing your
authentic emotions so we're actually
trying to figure that out is how do we
apply that in our leadership style and
especially in a workplace so what's your
take on this touchy-feely kind of
leadership style oh well I I went to a
different business school
this course potentially at least when I
wet could have been antithetical to
everything that people believe and and
that was pretty rough but I understand
where you're coming from I I
I think it's do we have a therapist in
the group here it is a step up the I I
think it's important God as I was saying
before to treat people in a way where
they feel secure where they feel valued
where they feel that you must tell the
truth and there are different ways of
doing that but in our investment process
for example we I was going to say
something like we encourage that people
come forward with different points of
view in fact we demand it I it's not
encouraging and and that's because I did
I proved a terrible investment as the
second investment we did and we lost
money and it was incredibly devastating
to me because as long as you're talking
about emotions I had some investor who
wanted to see us he started screaming at
me I had never been screamed up before
nobody in my house had ever raised their
voice and here's this person screaming
for about feels like an hour it was five
minutes completely out of control and I
mean I was I almost wanted to cry
actually because he was right I had made
it a the wrong decision and that's
because we didn't have as organized
investment process because we were new
so so best thing we did retrospectively
although it was gruesome was was to lose
that money because we set up a process
where everybody in at the firm at that
time it was just private equity now we
were doing a lot more things
we had to go around the table and
everyone had to express themselves and
they had to do it with something
negative about the proposed investment
risks that people didn't see and so we
got used to if you brought an investment
you knew you weren't going to get
universal approbation the job of
everyone around the table was to
critique it so that we we got rid of the
risk word understood it and the GSP we
call that giving feedback ah yeah but
it's it's it's giving feedback that gets
people angry that's the problem right so
so so you you have to set up an
environment where people feel secure
that that that act of criticism is not
personal it's impersonal it has nothing
to do with you bringing the deal it has
nothing to do with them pointing out the
shortfalls in the deal because every
deal will be treated exactly the same
and every person will have that same
role so what we tried to do as part of
an overall I don't know whether it's
touchy-feely or you know it's more in
institutional comfort for individuals is
to have that direct conversation in a
way that may made it non personal and so
so the concept of worrying about these
things which is I think what you're
actually asking is is is is really
important to have an ongoing successful
business but to have the people in it
always feel protected and and we set up
processes like that and and you know we
have we have very very very low turnover
at our firm and and I guess the last two
or three years we were voted like the
best place to work in finance by pension
and investment age and some other stuff
and so forth so
to these issues is is really important
you mentioned not not keeping those
criticism personal but I actually want
to get a little bit more personal with
you which is I want to learn more about
your personal background and motivations
so when you were first graduating from
HBS what motivated you back then and now
now what motivates you now and how has
that changed over the years
are there few answers to that when I
remember interviewing it it's a shame
this is video.i that that when I was
graduating from college I was
interviewing with with some employer and
they said what what do you want to be
why do you want to work here I and I
said well I I want to be a telephone
switchboard the person looked at me said
what are you talking about I said I want
to have all these inputs running up my
arm going to my head twist him around
and shoot him out some other place
that's what I want to do as a process
and the guy looked at me and said you're
wrong for us but but by the time I was a
little more you know sort of developed
graduating from business school I still
wanted to do the same thing it's
insatiable need to learn what's going on
and see something new and and do
something as a result of that and that's
that's never really stopped now that
that expresses itself in in different
ways I also wanted to make a lot of
money I guess you're not allowed to say
that anymore because that's
unfashionable or you only have to do it
through capital gains with new apps but
but that back back in the olden days you
sort of did it you know with more
current income and so I I had I had
$1,400 when I graduated
from from money that somebody a group of
people gave me on my bar mitzvah I
didn't even know my parents had held it
aside and I I was getting married so I
saw this wonderful ring at Tiffany's for
1,300 so I sort of looked at it I said
don't you have something a little better
I might as well blow the whole thing so
I spent 1,400 I started at zero so I I
decided I needed fuel so that was one of
my objectives but the basic objective
was was to put yourself in situations
were the the learning curve was so steep
and and the outcomes were so
consequential that it just was going to
be really fascinating and interesting
and fun and I'm still doing that and I
love it it's great I saw yesterday I had
Henry Kissinger come over he was doing a
video for the Schwartzman Scholars and
it's nice of Henry to do that he's on
our advisory board and we were walking
down the hall after he'd done this video
and and you know he said something like
geez Steve you know like 91 and a half I
still feel like I'm in my 30s and and he
said he said I think you're the same I
said yeah except I'm not 91 and a half
but but but but I you know feel exactly
the same way and he said you'd never
retire would you and I I said well why
would I retire my life so interesting
and I'm learning all the time and I'm
traveling all over the world and it's
great it's fantastic and he said yes he
said I do what would I do for no
compensation and I said yeah I get it I
mean absolutely I mean it's as you'll
find because there are mostly young
people in the audience that when you
find something you love and you're good
at it and you know you go to your touchy
feely quarters and you're self
actualized
right I mean that's that's what it's
like that's the game it's it's it's not
about money it's about creation it's
about feeling of you know you're totally
alive every day and it's interesting and
you run into heads of state or or
finance ministers and my kind of
industry or what unique transactions or
doing things that are the biggest in the
world with great returns and doing
unusual things you're always out on a
frontier this type of life is completely
seductive and and it's it's not age
determined it's really it's really about
you and I remember when I was
interviewing for a job in was graduated
from business school and I went to some
firm and you know you meet a lot of
people when you're interviewing it's
very interesting and I was sitting in
front of a guy who looked like he was in
his 80s named his name was Clifford
Michelle and he had all these bound
volumes of financings and things he'd
done and the guy had these brilliant
blue eyes and he was sitting alertly and
he's in his 80s and the guy was amazing
and I said you know what I want to be
him I want to be somebody at that age
can do what he's doing because he's
completely engaged with life you can do
that and that's the fun of it and that's
what I wanted to do and you know I was
lucky to be in an industry that was
going through enormous expansion at the
time when I was a young person and so I
was lucky and I didn't blow myself up
that was good too boy and and I have one
saying and those of you who are
interested in finances he's apparently
like 12 people in your whole school now
you know that that
there are no brave old people in finance
they usually get blown up by the time
they're 40 and if they're given
authority by the time they're 45 because
you always have to have balanced risk
you always have to worry about your
downside if I could say just one thing a
little commercial for Schwartzman
Scholars Program this is like really a
wonderful thing we're doing it's like
the roads except you get to go to
genoise University where we have a
distinguished graduate and and and it's
going to be marvelous introduction to
China for one year program where you
know be taught in English which is
universal language and you know you have
three different majors but we're going
to start out with a core courses
everything about China and have a
leadership course designed by the other
business school where they have cold
weather on the other side of the country
and then you'll have course in your
major everybody will get a mentor from
the real world some of the people I
haven't disclosed yet I mean there's
some of the most famous people in the
world and you get to take trips around
China I meet the leaders of the country
and and then we'll have a steady flow of
really fascinating people who come to
Beijing doing this in a new building
that we built that looks like a college
at Oxford or Cambridge except it's looks
like a Chinese building but the same
thing residential college and we're
having some meeting Rob I think later
today you know where I guess people are
allowed to come so so where is this
mystery meeting okay so I got my
commercial in which I wasn't supposed to
do but then again I'm an entrepreneur
thank you Steve thank you for answering
all the questions with such tremendous
candor really appreciate it at this
point I'm going to have everyone here in
the audience have the opportunity to ask
Steve any questions you want there are
two mics going around the auditorium
Ryan will left Carolyn on the right
we're also taking questions from Twitter
especially if you're sitting up there
we don't have mics there so please tweet
your questions to GSP pftt I'll start
with a question from Twitter sure so
this is a question that came in through
Twitter as you grew Blackstone how did
you ensure you got to the right people
for the right seats to the right people
for the right seats at Blackstone how do
hiring is a wonderful exercise it's
really fun and well what you're trying
to do is is match people's capability
with with who they really are one thing
we're doing this wars in Scholars
Program is trying to do to figure out
who will be great Future Leaders and
then give them a year to learn about
China and people say you know how do you
know who's going to be good and you have
to talk to them it's not a resume resume
is like a building block are they
smarter they dumb if if they're dumb you
don't see them but but smart people come
in much different versions and and you
know when people like myself meet other
people I I don't know how to interview
anybody they walk in to your room and
they sit down and you look at them and
somebody says something or they have
something on the resume that's
interesting this is you know like the
somebody's won the World Chess
Championship and still runs the 400
meters in less than four minutes and you
go when you spend time to do all this
stuff and you start a conversation and
what you're trying to do is figure out
how flexible their minds are
how emotionally stable they are how will
they do under stress are they
self-reliant what what's their ability
to express themselves sometimes you can
see fear in people's eyes this is
usually not a good thing right fear I
mean like complete fear what are they
doing sitting there I'm sort of easy
they shouldn't be scared of me if
they're scared of me they're going to be
scared of somebody else and and that's
not good at least from a sales
perspective you know being scared so
there are all kinds of things that
people will tell you and you're trying
to burrow into their head and predict
future behavior and and if you can do
that and you have certain criteria that
they have to be nice we don't we don't
hire anybody that's not nice or anybody
that's political that's what happens
because they're a bunch of there's
entrepreneurs stuff in the air here so
you don't have to hire anybody who's
disagreeable just because they want to
be hired you don't have to do that so
you can make whatever culture you want
to make it's hard at the beginning
because not everybody wants to join you
because you're not successful so you're
desperate right but you'll find that you
don't do well unless you're hiring
people who are consistent with your
values so you've got to know yourself
and you got to stick to those kind of
people meritocracy good thing you know
sort of being able to operate
horizontally instead of being you know
sort of a controlled monster we can't do
those you can't have those people around
even if they're smart even if I see
movies with people who were like that
and smart it's it doesn't work well as
you get more mature you can have
exceptions but basically you have to
have people who you think can really
adapt really have a gift really are nice
really can communicate
and you have to imagine them under big
stress how will they behave will they be
honest things like that thank you
do we have more question right there
so when you were first starting your
business all entrepreneurs have to sort
of overcome an established order in your
case you mentioned that you had a great
team wearing a brand new jersey and you
found it hard to get people to deal with
you so to speak what motivates that sort
of conservatism how did you overcome
that and and how did you sort of build
Blackstone into today's establishment
finishing the last answer one of the
things as you're hiring people that
people over 40 are their reputation
below that they change they adapt and
they're over 40 if you're interviewing
somebody and you think they're a good
person but like five people tell you
they're really not don't believe
yourself believe the five people who've
had experiences with them don't let your
own perception somebody who's really a
set personality overrule the other stuff
every time I did it I was wrong so I've
learned some lessons the question about
the world not accepting new things and
how do you change it I learned that
other than it's Stanford and you know
this part of California people basically
don't like change as distressing as it
is to imagine that they don't like
change every time we've tried to change
something
for example we renovate renovating a
hotel in London that was called
Claridge's and you
very prominent and we bought it 1995 and
it was quite rundown it needed to be you
know sort of modernized in a variety of
ways I mean I got these endless barrage
of things don't change it right don't
change it it's so wonderful don't change
a stick of furniture even though you
were sitting in a couch and your knees
were over your eyes right don't change
anything and you know you get sort of
like protests and so forth oh so we
change things but but we didn't change
him bad we changed him good and I had
one particular person who was born there
during World War two who you know really
became very unhappy and so you know we
did the change with English heritage
everything was like beautifully done and
at the end of that he wrote me this long
letter saying how wrong he was and and
how obnoxious he was and this is a
famous person and it's absolutely
wonderful and I just wanted to tell you
I was completely wrong you usually don't
get that satisfaction but but change is
really hard for a lot of people and and
so you have to recognize that whenever
you start something new and you go out
of your way to make them comfortable
because you can introduce them to change
at Blackstone of it's not directly
applicable we keep doing new things and
as long as you you really do good
returns I and people know that you care
about them the investors and you'll
never do anything to hurt them and
you're on their team on their side and
you're just like trying to make their
lives better they have to understand
your motives and if you can explain your
motives and your motives are direct and
pure really I mean
we want to make money but we we only
want to do this for the benefit of
people we're investing for and if they
never if they understand that you never
will introduce a product that that is
not terrific you believe completely in
it that's your business then what
happens is they start trusting you and
they should and that's building up in
effect brand equity Steve I wish we had
more time with you but I've saved
actually a last question that I want to
ask you and it has become a view from
the top tradition and it's a question we
all had an answer when we apply to the
GSB which is what matters most to you
and why you all answered this and they
they all answered it very well to be
sitting here today what matters to me
most is excellence and delivering sort
of a vision into reality
it could be commercial it could be you
know in the art business it could be
imagining something that's never been
done or beautiful and making that happen
that's that's what I really love doing
and you know sitting in a in a room
that's perfectly beautiful from every
angle that gives me pleasure having
investments that are fantastic and work
out right that gives me pleasure
a perfectly hit
tennis ball
against a great player so they can't get
it and they're better than you that
gives me pleasure all of these types of
visualizations where you're executing
perfectly give me pleasure so you know
what was that
so it's a psychology course where they
had the bird that kept hitting something
to get you know they put some electrode
in its brain and it would hit the bar to
keep getting you know stimulated with
the with the pleasure I do that except
I'm not a bird and I don't have that but
but basically you know people like that
and there are a lot of different ways
where you can create that scenario and
and I I love a perfect sunset I love
these just wonderful things that they
all line up and they're they're just
excellent excellent so that's what I
like maybe I wouldn't be admitted here
yes well well to the pursuit of
excellence and thank you for your time
here with us thank you